welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Steven Davis a professor of Religious
Studies specializing in the history of
ancient and medieval Christianity with a
particular focus on the eastern
Mediterranean and the Near East since
2006 he has served as executive director
of the Yale monastic archaeology project
conducting field work and training
graduate students at two sites in Egypt
the white monastery near so hog and the
monastery of John the little in Wadi not
rune today we talked with professor
Davis about life and death in late
ancient and early medieval Egyptian
monasteries welcome professor Davis
thank you very much to pleasure be here
let's begin with an overview you've
written recently written an article
about the work that you did at both
sites so why don't we begin with you
giving us an overview of the projects
sure my problem my projects focus on
monastic sites in Egypt ancient
monasteries and we began this work in
2006 in the north of egypt in egypt the
Nile flot flows north and so the north
is lower egypt lower down in the river
this site was in wadena troon and we in
2006 we began surveying the site and
it's at this amazing site it's about a
kilometer and a quarter by a kilometre
across and there are over 80 unexcavated
structures that are visible by means of
seeing mounds sort of mounds on top of
the sand that sort of marked the
location of these structures okay and so
we began the first season doing some
surveys and also excavating an ancient
trash dump at this thing and then the
following season we began excavating a
residence of monastic residence that was
right next to that trash dump two years
later I took on a second
light in Egypt in southern Egypt that's
Upper Egypt at sohag the white monastery
and at that site we have a variety of
different sort of remains there's a an
ancient church monumental church huge
church that survives from the fifth
century there as well as a range of
other are no well a gigantic well and
one of the places that we've been
working as a smaller church with a tomb
under it okay so I'm curious I don't
normally associate monasteries with
Egypt sure of course so I guess I'm
curious how why are you focused on
monasteries and how did you find these
sites yeah so much of Arc sort of
cultural knowledge about monasteries
comes through Europe weren't the name we
think of like monasteries like in the
name of the movie the name of the rose
but actually the the earliest monk monks
came out of Egypt and Syria and in fact
Egypt and antiquity developed a
reputation for being the sort of
birthplace of early Christian
monasticism and there are a variety of
expressions of it there were monks who
went into the desert to live by
themselves there were monks who wanted
to live by themselves but sort of
loosely congregated in sort of clusters
and then there were some more organized
communities that followed a common rule
more similar to what we have in mind
when we think of monasticism in medieval
Europe how I found these these places /
the one that's that's covered in sand I
mean that seems yeah so the history of
monasticism in Egypt is interesting it
has its roots in like the fourth century
and the sites that we work on started
around then and continued to be active
up through the late medieval period and
in some cases the modern period but
there was a kind of decline in
monasticism during the late medieval
period but about fifty years ago in the
1960s the Coptic Orthodox Church has
really promoted monasticism again and
there's been this boom monasteries that
were either defunct or down to just a
few monks
now have hundreds and so both of the
sites that we're working at the remains
are either within the bounds of active
monasteries or right next door to them
and so one of my job's is director the
project is not only working with the
material culture itself studying that
for what we can know about ancient
monasticism but I have a lot of
interaction with contemporary monks as
well as the Egyptian inspectors who
accompany us in our work so it's an
interesting sort of contemporary
cultural enterprise in making sure that
the relationships are sound the
communication is clear this is one of
the reasons I enjoy the work actually
how long will it take you to uncover you
know whatever it is you're uncovering I
mean I would imagine it's a large
building that's right so the residents
that we excavated starting in 2007 and
we actually just completed the
excavation this past year is about 25
meters by 25 meters it's made of mud
brick it has about 20 rooms in it
including a large courtyard in the
middle and so it took us that long six
years yeah we have a I mean our method
of doing archaeology is very painstaking
yes we're sort of taking layers and sort
of documenting not only what's in the
ground but how it came to be in the in
the form it is now so we were able to
sort of figure out how it collapsed
after it fell out of use and one of the
interesting discoveries that we've made
in this residence is one of the rooms
had extensive wall painting program as
well as a number of inscriptions a lot
of which a sort of unpainted on plaster
a lot of this plaster had fallen off the
walls prior to our coming sometime after
the building was no longer in use and so
we found these fragments of painted
plaster in the sand fill that was in the
room and our painted plaster specialist
Julian Pike piece these these fragments
together like a jigsaw puzzle and ended
up coming up with these amazing wall
paintings
of monastic saints of martyrs and so
it's we have we have an idea of when
when the monks who lived in this
residence and we know the dating of this
residence from the inscriptions way too
dated and inscriptions from the 10th
century so we know a little bit about
when they walked into this room what
they would have seen the sort of
interaction between monks coming into
the room to pray for example and what
they would have seen on the walls where
different figures sort of models for
their own piety would have been located
what they would been able to read on the
walls dedicatory inscription prayers etc
so you must have to have to have a lot
of patience and then how exciting to
have something to be completely covered
and then you uncover it and then you
know six years later you're able to see
you know what this structure was all
about I mean it must be fascinating it's
a fascinating discovery but there's also
it's interesting it's also frustration
so you just narrated this process of
sort of uncovering actually after every
season we cover it up again we backfill
this is a building that is made of mud
brick and basically the best way that we
can preserve it is to take the sand that
we have excavated sifted as now clean
sand and backfill it into the space if
we would leave this building exposed
because of the the elements the Sun the
wind Kate very occasionally the rain it
would suit you would soon see the
results of deterioration and there are
examples in the area of structures that
have been excavated previously by other
teams where they have left them open and
you know and there's also sometimes
human interventions vandalism and things
like that so in that sense we don't
always get the gratification of at that
particular site at least of seeing it
sort of displayed and this is one of the
challenges in archaeology because our
responsibility is not only the
investigation the excavation itself but
it's also figuring out how to be
responsible with this cultural heritage
and sometimes that means very specific
conservation methods so that we can
display it and other times where that's
beyond our ability at this point or
beyond the level of expense that we can
can do and so we take the best approach
that we can to make sure that for future
investigators they want to come back in
they can find this building in good
shape and do their own studies
interesting so let's talk a bit about
the findings and the implications of
those findings at both of the sites sure
so I've said a little bit about this
residence I've talked about the wall
paintings but there's other things that
are interesting about this residence
there's a number of kitchen
installations in this residence and from
those kitchen installations we have
gotten basically leavings from the ovens
that we have done archeo botanical
analysis on and we can get an idea of
the kind of diet just amongst have
actual pieces of food yeah sort of like
remains of grapes green Wow beans I mean
we have an idea of some of some of what
they ingested I'm just thinking it's all
mixed in with sand and you have to like
extract the beans and the grains from
the sand that must be yeah there's
particular method methods of location
and to in order to separate the sand
from these other elements so that's one
example on another example from that
particular building is we see the ways
that the the monks renovated their their
spaces so you know we just did yeah
we've gone through this whole process of
renovating buildings at Yale the
colleges have gone through yes in
renovations well the monks were doing
this with their own buildings they were
sometimes walls would become would sort
of semi collapse or become weak and they
would reinforce it so we have really
thick walls they would close up windows
they would open up rooms so it's a you
see the building as a kind of dynamic
living object and the way that the monks
sort of interacted with their space so
that's that's the site in the north in
the South we've been doing a variety of
things and I mentioned a small church
with a tomb under it and probably our
most surprising discovery came out of
that this was a church that had been
excavated by
the Egyptian inspectors starting in 2002
when we came in we cooperated with them
and then did some further excavations as
well as conservation of what remained
there's some wall paintings but within
the tomb it's a very small space and one
of the things that we did was conserve
the clean and conserve the the paintings
that we found in there and if a couple
of years ago after a stage of that
cleaning we we kind of came to a
discovery on one wall of this spate this
tomb space is an image of a human human
image and it's an image of shenouda who
was the famous leader of this monastery
back in the 5th century and as an
inscription and accompanying actually in
greek accompanying this this figure and
he's he's standing and he's holding a
crown in one of his hands and his other
hand arm is partially preserved he would
have been holding a crown there and
after this cleaning stage we realized
that he was flanked by two figures
originally we thought they might have
been saints but you could see edges of
wings so these figures were angels and
this the placement of a human figure
between angels in this particular
posture is very much related to funerary
representation and so that combined with
the content of the inscription led us to
conclude that it's very likely that this
particular tomb was prepared for this
famous figure and we sort of came up out
of the tomb and looked at each other and
realize way wait a minute we couldn't
believe that this that that's what the
conclusion we were drawing so that was a
very surprising but wonderful discovery
what there's also a church there my
colleague Bentley Layton in the
Religious Studies department has been
doing architectural documentation on
that church and as part of that work we
were trying to clarify some
architectural elements and we wanted to
excavate a niche in one of the rooms a
sort of upstairs in this church and in
doing that we need
to clean and excavate the floor and in
doing that we found we ran across
manuscript fragments one of the things
that this monk shenouda was known for
was producing the largest corpus of
literature and Coptic that we have and
there's an international project right
now editing his works and at we knew
that a lot of these works were
originally kept somewhere in this church
and had been disseminated like in the
eighteenth nineteenth centuries all over
the world so we in order to study him
you have to go to like Moscow in Paris
Cairo and all these different places but
we had never been absolutely sure where
these texts have been kept where the
sort of archived webinars to confirm
that at least for a particular period of
time this room was used to store those
manuscripts some of the matchup and so
they essentially when when when people
in the monks had had taken the
manuscripts out of that room some of the
brittle edges had broken off and so that
was that was another really neat
discovery right right so I understand
that you are not done there that you
will continue work in both places yes do
you have any thoughts as to what you may
find or perhaps what you would hope to
find sure in the South the white
monastery one of our one of the things
it is not so much a finding but one of
our responsibilities is to make sure
that the the church remains in good
shape their parts of the church that are
hazardous so this this citrus is still
in use by the Coptic community and yet
their spaces where walls are kind of
threatening to fall down and so one of
the things that we have going on at
least next is is some consolidation work
on that at our other site we're in the
process of preparing a book documenting
the excavation of this this resonance
but we have about 70
buildings did you choose from and so
what I would like to find I would like
to work on is getting some comparison
looking at some other resonances seeing
what other art historical evidence is
yielded from that one of the things
about doing monastic archaeology is we
simply there simply has not been a lot
of it done you know handful of projects
over the years and why do you think that
is well there's a there's an interesting
history in archaeology especially in
Egypt so traditional sort of classical
archaeology in Egypt was always looking
for the sort of Veronica mains let's go
to the front of temples and a lot of the
later historical layers Coptic and
Islamic layers were sort of layered over
those remains and so the archaeologists
would simply sort of dig through an
early discard a lot of this valuable
historical evidence to get to what they
wanted to get to right and and so and so
I think it's important to pause and look
at these later periods to see what sorts
of developments were taking place in the
way that people were living and the way
that people were were dying the way that
people were burying loved ones right
within monasteries so that's one of the
one of the things I think is it was
really important about this work and it
gives us a real kind of textured sense
of everyday life from you know the the
lading ancient period 4th 5th 6th
centuries up to the medieval period ok
well thank you so much for being here
with us today it's been fascinating and
we'll look for more work to come yeah
for sure ok for more information about
professor Davis and his research please
visit our website at yale edu slash
mcmillan report be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
you